i want to read this
from wikipedia i just want to read it
from wikipedia so the audience can go
look for it
here's cultural hegemony when earlier
uh uh we were talking about
antonio gramsci this is him okay antonio
gramsci
the marxist intellectual developed the
notion of hegemony and adverse advocated
the establishment of a working-class
intelligence intelligentia so in marxist
philosophy culture germany is a
domination cultural diverse
society by the ruling class which
manipulates of the the culture of the
society the beliefs
manipulates it manipulates the culture
of society the beliefs
explanation perceptions values mores so
that the imposed ruling class worldwide
becomes
accepted cultural norm the universally
valid dominant ideology would justify
the social political
and economic status quo as natural and
inevitable
perpetual and beneficial for every
social class
rather than a as artificial social
construst
that benefits only one ruling class so
in in other words the way i take it
is look let's confuse the hell out of
everybody
let's confuse them and if you look at in
the last 18 months what was the biggest
thing that the marxist movement got
that helped them drive that agenda even
more maybe not 18 months 15 months
is covered why covet shut us down
so california new york illinois
michigan a lot of these states shut down
texas
florida many of these places were open
while these other states were not but
this shutdown got us to
accept sending people money paying
people for their rent
the person who owns that real estate
property that needs to collect rent is
not getting rent not from the government
not from the individual
they got a little bit of the ppp loan
but they're sitting there saying i can't
sustain this for for
too long oh let's extend the moratorium
but remember what do you want me to do
well you got you're rich
you can afford it dip into your savings
but i just barely bought this
duple you know this apartment i don't
have that much money in the bank account
i'm gonna run doesn't matter you are
rich
you're categorically rich you got to be
able to pay for this and gradually
people said maybe this
marxist stuff isn't that bad maybe this
saying we can send money to people we
can print money we can send money to
people
in the last 15 months i would have to
say to you
they made so much progress in the last
15 months
the agenda has won so much because the
divisiveness the the division the
them being divided has advanced them so
much
are you optimistic that
based on history tough
heroes rise up that are not afraid to
bully the bully
or are you in a place where you feel
we're at a tipping point where their
agendas
unfortunately gonna advance even more
today
than ever before simply because they
have the tools today that they did not
have
a hundred years ago when this movement
began
okay you've asked a terribly important
question
um so if if people have been partially
listening up to this point i hope to
listen very carefully
during the covet crisis that we've that
we've
been subject to and also subjected
ourselves to
active duty service members it was tough
for us to get
even our service members to work
sometimes if they were non-mission
essential personnel
because we would like so many other
businesses or organizations cut down on
the number of people that were
that were allowed to come to work
instead of 100 percent manning you went
to 75
then you went to 50 and at one point
you're down to 25
manning and so our service members are
staying at home trying to telework
and it was different from base to base
this was not you know top down driven
policy
base to base because it was too
dangerous to come to work but there were
waivers being granted for people to go
downtown
in various cities and participate in
black lives matter rallies
that were smashing windows and lighting
things on fire
okay now now we have
we have a right to go and participate in
rallies protests etc just not in uniform
okay so i'll make that clear
work we're saying that
in fact it was the office of special
counsel that that determined
black lives matter last year they
determined that black lives matter is
not a politically partisan organization
it's not involved in politics it's not a
political organization
which is false it's completely political
uh and its founders have said so since
at least 2015 in interviews they said
remarxist democrat party is not far
left enough for us we need to move to
socialism uh we have a marxist
agenda uh we're trained marxist
organizers and we're trying to
revolutionize the system okay that's all
very clear language so it is very
political
now to say that service members cannot
come to work
because it's too dangerous because of
covet but that because but we have to
honor their rights
to go and participate in protests even
highly politically charged and
potentially violent and dangerous
protests like black lives matter
protests
turned into during the last year is a
very odd
to say to put it lightly uh double
standard
but here's to your point the question of
where we stand
as a country am i optimistic about
potential outcomes and what courageous
voices can do
this is why it's the crux of the matter
it's why it's so important to me
as an active duty service member to
speak up now
early and often about what i'm seeing
take place for people that don't
understand history
i get that you might be at odds with me
or disagree with my method
my approach my tactic uh it's been
embarrassing somewhat for the services
for me to be talking publicly i
understand that completely
but what is far worse is for people to
not say anything
if they recognize how dangerous a path
we're walking
and to wait a year or two or three until
it's far too late
for us to reverse the radical trend
that's occurring in our society
to a to a single
to a single party system i'll say i'm
not talking just
i'm not talking republicans versus
democrats at all here i'm talking about
the establishment of a marxist communist
regime
in this country and you're saying we're
well on our path to doing that
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
you